chris flexon making his first start his
mariner's debut
see what he did last year in korea 21
starts eight four record era just over
three
tommy la stella drives once center field
and deep staying in the yard out there
is taylor tremell reunited with farhan
zadie the gm they both are together in
the dodger organization
smooth fielding evan white just another
day at the office on that one
2-2
swaying and a miss
welcome to seattle chris flexing one two
three first
and that lineup was brought to you by
your bay area gmc dealers logan webb on
the hill tonight for the giants
stroked to longoria who checks the
runner
most guys have four or five or even six
got him
[Applause]
got him
what a nice comeback so that helped me
out a little bit
angie thank you good stuff as flutterson
strikes out
one and two
clang and a miss chris flexing
good start six up six down three k's
here is ty france who has grounded out
to third we're scoreless bottom of the
third inning
that's hit well left center field
to it again
[Applause]
ty
france
and the mariners have a one-nothing lead
time france's first home run to mariners
first home run of the season
[Applause]
he charged that baby
great opportunity to add on to that very
thin one-nothing lead here in the bottom
of the fourth
and here's the cage taylor trammell
looking still looking for that first
major league hit and the o2 on the way
swinging a drive into the gap in the
right center field yes strepski on the
right can't get to it there it is
off the wall of the hop ronnie third
heading home evan white will score
taylor tremell in its second base with
his first major league hit and rbi
double into the gap in right center the
mariners lead the giants two to nothing
and that is rbi number two for taylor
trammell's major league career
a double into the gap in right center
field on an 02 pitch from logan webb
he drives home evan white easily
and that ball comes out of the ball game
a great souvenir for the kid
taylor trammell welcome to the big
leagues young man
welcome to the show
[Applause]
and his fourth run batted in
her home run teamwise
and then
three consecutive doubles produce a
couple runs
in the fourth
it's crawford
they get the middle they get the back
and that is lovely
what a double play turn started by the
gold glove shortstop jp crawford
exceptional range to his right
big delivery super bowl right off the
end of the bat
and gets rid of it quickly so that ty
franz can make the turn before crawford
can even get to the base and they throw
him out by a couple of steps
an exceptional double play
2-2 pitch
[ __ ] him out
chris flexing outstanding five innings
in his mariner debut
in the building but his heart
was in indy and his boys
with sucks hitting a half court just
inside half court a banker to send
gonzaga to the national championship
game monday
and look at marco gonzalez there's no
bigger cheerleader in the city right now
wow
going too
swinging and a miss he got him
perfect
slider so four pitches four sliders
got him
whistler comes in gets a couple of
strikeouts 0-2 here
right three goal getting looking
four strikeouts
for
of the season as crawford strikes out
two away
with the breaking ball
85 miles an hour middle of the plate
crawford out in front of it
make delivery super mowing
just enough downward movement on the
breaking ball
broken bat looper type france
have been white
ending over
here's marunta
mitch drives one deep left field
gideon
[Applause]
lead
[Applause]
second home run tonight by the banners
two
first two home runs of the season ty
france had a solo blast
with two outs in the third
so jeremy mercedes and his ninth a b
flight out
to mike trout
stealing moore settling under this
five years with the phillies prior to
that 2-1 pitch
popped it up evan white plenty of room
two outs as we check in with brett adam
and set him down right here the o2
[Applause]
ed hard nice short hop by j.p crawford
takes his time inning over
that's starting not bad either
alex dickerson
easy play seeger one pitch one out
[Applause]
making some noise and the 2-2 to
crawford swinging a chopper to hopper to
the second baseman france has it throws
the first and the ball game is over the
mariners shut out the san francisco
giants